are you feeling the sympathy for the
devil oh god that was awful
I should think someone else I won't
though so hey everybody
there is a trailer for season 3 of
daredevil and despite the fact that for
me the Bloom has been off the rows of
the Marvel Netflix shows for a while I
can't help but get excited by that
because well because kingpin that's why
he was he was not the only good thing
about the first season but almost
everything that worked in some way
revolved around him and seeing so much
focus on him knowing he's coming back
getting Vincent D'Onofrio back in this
part all just and that that makes me
genuinely excited and from what I
understand they're not cribbing any
specific story line that the kingpin has
been a part of previously which means
that anything could happen if they're
not directly pulling from a story that's
been done before who knows where this
goes I am really excited and it's it's
gonna be interesting that he comes back
to power at the same time as daredevil
you know as Matt seems to be hitting his
lowest point anyway he seems
disillusioned with with his whole
mission and with what he does or at
least with the way he had been going
about it up to this point so we've got
this whole element where it looks like
kingpin is looking to pin daredevil as a
menace I'm a little bit like honestly
like Jake J jonah Jameson would do a
spider-man but it's what's interesting
about it is usually with their something
like this when there's base
a framing of the hero it doesn't always
coincide with the hero themselves
getting to a position where that becomes
more plausible like to take spider-man
for example you know Jameson would
constantly be blaming him for this that
and the other and it just it just
wouldn't job it's just like why would
anyone ever believe that I mean some
people still do because they'll believe
anything that's imprint but you know
with this it looks like Matt himself is
being pushed to the point where it
becomes much more believable that he
would cross these lines that our fake
daredevil that we see at the end of the
trailer appears to be doing and I did go
back and re-watch it because initially I
was like oh is this like a vision thing
like oh because you know because Matt is
in the in the thing he was basically in
the first season you know with just the
up in the front you know the scarf thing
and facing I'm against daredevil I was
like oh is this like a metaphorical so a
Superman 3 thing fight that's going on
no you know they're getting a closer
look at him that's not the same jawline
it's not the same voice it's a different
actor so I and this has probably been
confirmed elsewhere but you know me and
research I'm pretty dang positive that
that is going to be our version of
bull's eye whether or not he gets called
bull's eye
I don't know but we see him with a gun
we see him throwing stuff around a bit
you know which is kind of the signature
stuff with bullseye and if you're gonna
have somebody masquerading as daredevil
you know you might as well use the
opportunity to introduce bullseye
anyways doing that sort of thing and it
also sort of brings up an interesting
thing with that daredevil again much
like spider-man is a very good candidate
for this kind of their reputation gets
marred by someone pretending to be them
storyline because the mask is so up so
face obscuring if you can if you can get
a replica costume it's actually really
easy to frame this guy because you
he can't be identified so much of his
face is covered so all you have to do is
recreate that mask and yeah you you can
you can seem like him and and really
just mess with everything and I like the
appearance that it looks like Fisk is
really gonna just mess with like he
wants to dwell and live and revel in
making Matt Murdock and daredevil pay
for everything that he has endured for
the last couple seasons worth of
television and I I in revenge and
grudges tend to be a pretty standard
generic motivation but if you can get
somebody who is really reveling in it
like the way that Khan in Star Trek 2
reveled in the in The Revenge of it if
you can get that right oh it's a
glorious thing and I'm hopeful because I
know kingpin has been magnificently
portrayed so far already missus done our
fair seems to really get this character
really well so against my better
judgement because my better judgment is
telling me that there has not been a
solid from start to finish at least tip
for me I know other people have liked
some of it but for me there has not been
a full season of the Marvel Netflix that
I've liked start to finish since the
first season of Jessica Jones you know
not all of them have been awful iron
fist season two was better than season
one but it still isn't great Luke Cage
season two was more consistent than
season one but I'm not sure it's highs
were as high as season one were Jessica
Jones season 2 was not very good
daredevil season 2 had a couple of
highlight bits in it but overall was not
nearly as strong as the first season
defenders was a mess you know I for me
the track record for Marvel Netflix is
not strong when I break it down how how
many seasons have worked in how many
haven't at the end of the day
for me oh and Punisher I always forget
about Punisher because I didn't finish
it I did I honestly I did go back
because enough people told me it gets
better later I tried I did think it in
two more episodes which puts me six
episodes ends in the thing I'm sorry I'm
still finding it really boring and
that's that's not a knock on anyone who
likes it if you liked it
great I'm envious but I couldn't get
through it so yeah that's the bye that
track record I should not be looking
forward to this but I see this trailer
and I bread I'm like oh yes
so guess my better judgment I am excited
but what about you what do you think
about the trailer for daredevil season 3
whatever it is you think drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
there's a bunch of stuff to do there's
buttons and there's links including one
to a patreon page if you're feeling so
generous so check that out if you feel
like it there's a bunch of other links
down there too but if you don't don't
sweat it because remember you're the
council I just run the meetings then
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]